basically i think with the rise of no
code tools virtual assistants all this
sort of stuff
like i think the average company and we
we do this at my company
could just be 30 more productive like we
we have basically one virtual assistant
hire for every two people that we have
that are on the team
and we give them like a training that's
like here's how to use virtual
assistants get all of the repetitive
stuff off your plate
and i just wish i could hire someone to
do that as a service where like
he or she sits in product meetings or
marketing or logistics team
and it's just like we're going to
automate these five pieces and just
continually does that across the company
where did you learn that from who that's
so so interesting to give
va's to every two people yeah i just
started doing it
when we started the company i think
that's pretty amazing
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road less travel never looking back